NEIGHBORING MISSOURI WANT TO
STOP PEOPLE FROM CROSSING STATE
LINES TO GET AN ABORTION.
>> WE'RE GOING TO DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO PROTECT EVERY CHILD IN
THE STATE, SO BANS ABORTIONS
WHEN THERE'S HEARTBEATS AND
BRAIN WAVES, AT EIGHT WEEKS.
IF THAT GETS OVERTURNED, THERE'S
AN 18 WEEK.
>> MISSOURI REPUBLICAN STATE
REPHAS BEEN CALLED THE NEW FACE
OF THE ANTIABORTION MOVEMENT.
SHE'S A LONGTIME ACTIVIST.
SHE HAS SIX KIDS.
SHE'S RUNNING FOR STATE SENATE.
AND SHE'S PUSHED FOR A LOT OF
LEGISLATION TO LIMIT ABORTION.
>> THERE ARE NUMBER OF
PROVISIONS IN THE INITIAL BILL
THAT I FILED MAKING SURE THAT
PLANNED PARENTHOOD IS NOT ABLE
TO BE A MEDICAID PROVIDER.
ALSO SOME ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS
TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE WHO ARE
AIDING OR ABETTING AVOIDING THE
LAWS OF MISSOURI ARE ABLE TO
HAVE SOME KIND OF A LEGAL
RECOURSE AGAINST STOPPING THAT.
>> SOME OF HER EFFORTS HAVE
FAILED.
EVEN WITH REPUBLICANS
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY IN
MISSOURI.
LIKE HER BILL TO IMPOSE
PENALTIES FOR HELPING PEOPLE GET
ABORTIONS OUTSIDE THE STATE.
WHICH DIDN'T PASS THIS YEAR.
>> THE BILL INTRODUCED WAS
REFERENCED IN POLITICO AS SORT
OF WHAT THE POST-ROE FEATURE
COULD LOOK LIKE.
THERE WOULD BE PENALTIES FOR
PEOPLE WHO WENT OUT OF STATE TO
SEEK ABORTIONS.
>> THAT'S WRONG.
THERE'S PENALTIES FOR PEOPLE WHO
AID OR ABET VIOLATING THE LAW.
IN FACT, WOMEN ARE EXPLICITLY
EXEMPTED FROM THAT.
>> WHAT WOULD AIDING AND
ABETTING BE?
>> SO RIGHT NOW, IF A WOMAN IN
MISSOURI IS WANTING TO SCHEDULE
AN ABORTION, SHE'LL CALL THE
LAST CLINIC THAT'S OPEN HERE IN
MISSOURI AND THAT CLINIC WILL
SCHEDULE AN ABORTION IN
ILLINOIS.
AND BOTH OF THE ENTITIES ARE
OWNED BY THE SAME LEGAL ENTITY,
AND SO THAT'S A COORDINATED
EFFORT TO AVOID THE LAWS OF THE
STATE OF MISSOURI.
>> SHE PLAYED A CRITICAL ROLE IN
MISSOURI'S 2019 ABORTION LAW
WHICH INCLUDES A TRIGGER BAN,
WHICH MEANS IF ROE FALLS,
ABORTION WILL IMMEDIATELY BECOME
ILLEE IN THE STATE.
>> MARY ELIZABETH COLEMAN IS
CLEARLY AMBITIOUS.
SHE'S VERY EXCITED TO IMPOSE HER
BELIEFS THROUGH POLICY ON THE
VAST MAJORITY OF MISSOURIANS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW SHE CAN FIX HER
FACE TO TALK ABOUT FAMILY VALUES
OR CONSERVATIVE VALUES FROM A
RELIGIOUS FRAME IN A STATE THAT
HAS SO FAILED TO PROVIDE
SERVICES, ADEQUATE HOUSING, JOB
OPPORTUNITIES, FOOD.
I MEAN, IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
>> OUR FREEDOM CANNOT BE BOUGHT
WITH THE BLOOD OF OUR CHILDREN.
>> OH, GOSH.
I WOULDN'T THINK OF IT AS A
PROFESSIONAL POLITICAL CAREER.
I THINK OF MYSELF AS KIND OF
TAKING MY TURN IN THE CITIZEN
LEGISLATURE, BUT I HAVE PRAYED
OUTSIDE OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
JUST REALLY A LONGTIME ADVOCATE
FOR PROTECTIONS FOR THE UNBORN.
>> HI.
GLAD TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
LISTEN, WHEN YOU LEAVE, I WOULD
LIKE TO SHARE SOME INFORMATION
ABOUT YOU ABOUT WOMEN'S HEALTH
CARE.
OTHER CLINICS I KNOW ARE SAFE
AND GIVE QUALITY CARE.
>> BONNIE LEE IS ALSO AN
ANTI-ABORTION ACTIVIST WHO PRAYS
IN FRONT OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
>> I'M SORRY I DIDN'T HAVE MY
MIC ON.
>> IT'S THE BABIES' LIVES.
THEY'RE INNOCENT.
WE FIGHT FOR THEM.
YOU HAVE A GOOD DAY, SIR.
>> LEE IS PART OF 40 DAYS FOR
LIFE, AN INTERNATIONAL
ANTIABORTION ORGANIZATION WHICH
SHE SAYS TAUGHT HER HOW TO
APPROACH WOMEN AND CONVINCE THEM
NOT TO GET ABORTIONS.
>> I WEAR THE VOICE ENHANCER
BECAUSE THIS BUSY STREET IS SO
LOUD, AND IF I ELEVATE MY VOICE,
THEY THINK I'M YELLING AT THEM.
>> THERE ARE PEOPLE IN THE
ANTIABORTION COMMUNITY WHO ARE
YELLERS.
>> YES.
AND THAT'S UNFORTUNATE.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET ANYONE TO
COME TALK WITH US IF YOU'RE
MEAN.
>> ONE TACTIC SHE LEARNED IS TO
RECOMMEND CRISIS PREGNANCY
CENTERS.
RELIGIOUS ORGANIZATIONS THAT
OFFER AID BUT NOT ABORTION.
WHO IS THERE TO HELP THEM AND
SAY WE CAN HELP YOU WITH CHILD
CARE?
WE WILL HELP YOU WITH GETTING
HOUSING, AND IF WE ON THE
SIDEWALK CAN BUILD A
RELATIONSHIP TO WHERE THEY'LL
COME OVER AND ACCEPT MAYBE SOME
ASSISTANCE, WE'RE HELPING
PEOPLE.
AND YES, THAT HELPS THE BABY.
>> NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THIS ROE V. WADE DECISION, OUR
WORK ISN'T FINISHED.
WE STILL NEED TO BE THERE
BECAUSE WOMEN WILL CONTINUE TO
FIND THEMSELVES IN AN UNEXPECTED
PREGNANCY.
AND SO WHAT BETTER WAY TO HELP
THEM THAN TO BE IN A PLACE WHERE
THEY'RE GOING, THINKING THEIR
ONLY CHOICE IS ABORTION.
>> YOU SAID THAT WOMEN SAY THE
REASON THEY WANT AN ABORTION IS
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T TAKE CARE OF
THE BABY, THEY CAN'T AFFORD THE
BABY.
DOES THAT EVER MAKE YOU WONDER
IF THERE'S SOMETHING MUCH
BROADER THAT'S WRONG WITH
SOCIETY ON A MUCH BIGGER SCALE
THAN JUST ABORTION?
LIKE WHY IS IT SO EXPENSIVE TO
HAVE A CHILD?
>> WELL, I THINK A LOT OF TIMES,
WHEN A WOMAN DOES FIND HERSELF
IN AN UNEXPECTED PREGNANCY, A
LOT OF TIMES SHE'S NOT MARRIED.
AND A LOT OF TIMES SHE'S GETTING
A LOT OF COERCION FROM THE
BOYFRIEND TO ABORT.
>> WELL, I JUST MEAN LIKE THE
SERVICES YOU OFFER, LIKE WHAT IF
ALL WOMEN COULD GET MEDICAL CARE
FOR THEIR INFANTS?
YOU KNOW, NOT JUST THOSE WHO
WERE DIRECTED AWAY FROM PLANNED
PARENTHOOD.
>> WOULDN'T THAT BE NICE?
>> ULTIMATELY, THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL FACTOR FOR THE
ANTIABORTION MOVEMENT HAS BEEN
THAT THERE WERE PEOPLE WHO
BOUGHT THE FALSE PREMISE THAT
THESE ANTIABORTION ACTORS WERE A
BUNCH OF REALLY CONCERNED
GRANNIES WHO WERE OUT IN FRONT
OF CLINICS, AS OPPOSED TO A
COORDINATED WELL FUNDED
POLITICAL OPERATION THAT WAS
DRAFTING LEGISLATION THROUGH A
LONG GAME LEGAL LENS.
>> I JUST THINK ABORTION IS THE
GREATEST EVIL WE HAVE RIGHT NOW
IN OUR COUNTRY.
THE IDEA THAT THE VALUE OF
SOMEONE'S LIFE WOULD BE
DIFFERENT BASED ON HOW OLD THEY
ARE IS REALLY HORRIFYING T